[Musica]
Signore e signori buonasera Il mio nome
è Francesco Fontanelli e sono un
prestigiatore un mago un'illusionista e
Mi sono appassionata la magia sin da
quando ero piccolo grazie a mio papà che
mi ha trasmesso questa passione e
quest'oggi vi vorrei raccontare di
alcune delle lezioni più importanti che
la magia mi abbia mai insegnato in
particolare vi vorrei parlare di
meraviglia e di quanto io ritenga che la
capacità di meravigliarci se qualcosa di
fondamentale che dovremmo allenare in
ogni giorno della nostra vita e per
parlarvi di meraviglia vi vorrei
raccontare del primo effetto magico che
io abbia mai eseguito di fronte a un
pubblico pensate avevo appena 6 anni e
quel giorno avevo con me un fazzoletto
rosso come questo che chiaramente passai
nel palmo della mia mano e poi lo inserì
nel pugno chiuso della mano sinistra
Dopodiché feci un gesto basilico ed
incredibilmente il mio fazzoletto Si
trasformò in un uovo
magico Non è vero
volete sapere il trucco volete che vi
sveli il segreto che di solito è quello
che mi chiedono sempre trucchi sempre
trucchi Beh siccome siamo al The x è
un'occasione speciale vi Voglio svelare
il trucco di questo mio primo effetto il
gioco è semplicissimo l'uovo è finto è
di plastica e è Forato e il fazzoletto
ci viene nascosto all'interno lo so una
volta che si scopre il tutto sembra
molto più semplice e banale di quanto
non si impensasse prima però sapete uno
dei miei più grandi idoli e maestri
Silvan dice che conoscere un gioco è
niente saperlo fare è già qualcosa
saperlo presentare è tutto quindi
lasciate che vi mostri tutte le piccole
accortezze e sottigliezze che vi
serviranno per poter presentare questo
effetto così che lo potrete riproporre
ad amici e parenti Mi raccomando se vi
riesce ditegli che ve lo ha insegnato
Francesco Fontanelli
invece non vi riesce Beh in quel caso
non dite niente Allora voi partite
prendendo con la mano destra sia il
fazzoletto che il vostro uovo tenendolo
nascosto in questo modo poi passate il
fazzoletto nell'altra mano per qualche
volta e Lasciateci cadere segretamente
il vostro uovo a questo punto arriva la
parte in cui si diventa tutti un po'
Pinocchio Eh ci viene il naso lungo
Perché Perché si dichiara tutti
apertamente che si andrà a inserire il
fazzoletto all'interno del palmo chiuso
della mano quando in realtà lo state
inserendo all'interno del Foro dell'uovo
poi a questo punto Fate il vostro gesto
magico e mostrate a tutti che avete
trasformato il vostro fazzoletto in un
uovo godendovi il vostro meritato
applauso
cose importanti Mi raccomando state
attenti a non mostrare l'uovo dalla
parte sbagliata altrimenti Il segreto
verrà spoilerato a tutti
Ora però ho una domanda per voi la
domanda è questa Secondo voi Qual è la
vera magia la vera magia è il primo
momento di stupore e meraviglia che
avete provato la prima volta quando
avete visto quel fazzoletto trasformarsi
in un uovo oppure la vera magia è il
trucco Il segreto che c'è dietro Beh
ovviamente questa non è una risposta che
spetta a me dare anche se personalmente
mi piace pensare
che la magia sia qualcosa
di questo tipo
Sì quest'oggi non sono qui per parlarvi
solo di alcuni trucchi magici ma vorrei
invitarvi a entrare nella tana del
Bianconiglio attraversare lo specchio
perché vorrei svelarvi quelli che sono i
veri segreti di noi prestigiatori così
che potrete riapplicarli nella vita di
tutti i giorni perché se ci pensate il
mago non è altro che un esperto di
problem solving perché perché deve
prendere un sogno impossibile e trovare
un metodo pratico per poterlo Riportare
nel mondo reale sul palcoscenico e
quest'oggi vi vorrei parlare proprio di
come noi prestigiatori riusciamo a
compiere questo processo di come
sostanzialmente riusciamo a realizzare i
nostri e i vostri sogni
e come si può unire il mondo della
meraviglia a quello della realtà Beh
attraverso il mondo della fantascienza
quello che vedete alle mie spalle è
Arthur see Clark un famoso scrittore
fantascientifico che scrisse tre leggi
tre leggi del suo mondo di fantascienza
che però sono anche tre leggi del mondo
dei maghi e sono diventati un po' i miei
tre mantra in particolare la prima legge
dice che ogni tecnologia
sufficientemente avanzata è quasi
indistinguibile Dalla magia che
innanzitutto È verissimo perché se io
mostrassi uno smartphone a un uomo di
Neanderthal questo molto probabilmente
mi prenderebbe per uno stregone e
contemporaneamente è anche il perfetto
riassunto di un gioco di prestigio
perché perché noi maghi che cosa
facciamo noi maghi inventiamo dei metodi
particolarmente ingegnosi utilizziamo
delle destrezze di mano percorriamo
delle vie alternative alle quali nessuno
aveva mai pensato prima che per noi sono
dei semplici trucchi ma per tutti gli
altri sono vera e propria magia quindi
sostanzialmente non c'è sogno che un
mago non possa realizzare infatti la
seconda legge di arthur's City Clark
dice che quando uno scienziato afferma
che qualcosa è possibile ha quasi sempre
ragione quando invece afferma che
qualcosa è impossibile ha molto
probabilmente torto basti pensare a
tutte le teorie scientifiche che sono
state confutate nel corso degli anni non
so per esempio per secoli si pensava che
fosse il sole a girare intorno alla
terra quando però qualcuno riuscì a
pensare fuori dagli schemi andare oltre
le convenzioni e i luoghi comuni
scoprendo così Copernico docet che in
realtà quello che fino a qualche momento
prima era ritenuto impossibile non si
trattava altro che della realtà che
tutti avevano davanti altri giochi sin
dall'alba dei tempi proprio come in un
gioco di magia Quindi abbiamo appurato
che noi maghi siamo bravi in questo a
creare tecnologie quasi indistinguibili
della magia che riusciamo addirittura a
rendere possibile l'impossibile Ma come
si può allenare questo approccio Beh
questo ce lo svela si crack nella sua
terza legge quando afferma che l'unico
modo per poter scoprire i limiti del
possibile è avventurarsi
nell'impossibile perché è proprio questo
il compito di noi prestigiatori noi
maghi dobbiamo istillare meraviglia
negli occhi di chi ci guarda dobbiamo
scardinare Ovvio dobbiamo mostrare che
la realtà non è sempre Come appare ma
soprattutto Dobbiamo creare il dubbio
nella costellazione dei pregiudizi di
chi ci sta osservando perché forse aveva
ragione Aristotele quando diceva che la
vita così come la filosofia è meraviglia
e che avremmo tutti bisogno di un
pizzico di stupore e di magia in più la
nostra quotidianità
Ora però siccome sono un mago so che
cosa state pensando sicuramente sarete
pensando Sì molto bello riuscire a
rincorrere i miei sogni a colpi di
bacchetta magica e meraviglia ma Come
può un gioco di prestigio ispirarmi a
realizzare i miei sogni Beh a me
piacciono molto gli esempi pratici
quindi lasciate che vi racconti la
storia di Edmond cartrettt ed un cartrit
è considerato uno dei padri della
Rivoluzione Industriale in quanto
inventore del telaio meccanico una
macchina straordinaria per l'epoca che
riusciva a tessere molto velocemente e
sapete come cartrait èbbe l'idea per
inventare la sua rivoluzionaria macchina
Beh quando vide quest'altra macchina un
automa fatto di ingranaggi e meccanismi
di metallo tipo quello del film Hugo
Cabret per capirsi che riusciva a
vincere a scacchi per l'epoca fece il
giro del mondo riuscì a battere anche
Franklin e Napoleone e quando kartett
vide questa automa pensò che se una
macchina fatta di metallo poteva
batterlo a scacchi allora lui poteva
inventare una macchina per tessere più
velocemente e così inventò il suo telaio
meccanico quello che carta it Però non
sapeva è che in realtà questo non era un
computer super all'avanguardia per
l'epoca ma si trattava di un vero e
proprio gioco di prestigio passatemi il
termine una truffa perché non si
trattava altro che di una scatola con un
doppio fondo all'interno del quale c'era
nascosto un nano che manovrava la
macchina durante la partita Ah cosa
importante dentro ci deve essere
nascosto qualcuno che sappia giocare
bene a scacchi Se no il gioco non
funziona la partita non viene vinta e
quindi vi ho dimostrato di un classico
esempio di come un gioco di prestigio
possa aiutarci a realizzare i nostri
sogni
Ma siccome sono un mago ancora una volta
so che cosa stai pensando sicuramente
starete pensando Sì molto bello però io
non devo né dare il via alla rivoluzione
industriale né tantomeno truffare
Napoleone nel concreto come posso
utilizzare questo approccio questa
tendenza verso la meraviglia nella mia
vita di tutti i giorni Beh sapete se c'è
una lezione che la magia mi ha insegnato
È che si può trovare qualcosa di
straordinario nell'ordinario che detta
così sembra una frase fatta molto bella
ma che cosa vuol dire trovare lo
straordinario nell'ordinario
Provate a rifletterci non vi è mai
capitato di ripensare a un momento
particolarmente felice della vostra vita
che magari non vi eravate goduti appieno
Forse per via di una stupidaggine oppure
a uno particolarmente triste che ha
affrontato col sorriso sarebbe risultato
meno pesante Ecco questo è quello che mi
ha insegnato la magia questo significa
trovare lo straordinario nell'ordinario
vuol dire riuscire ad essere presente
nei momenti felici e ad affrontare nel
migliore dei modi quelli più tristi e
infelici perché se c'è una lezione che
ho imparato nell'osservare la meraviglia
negli occhi degli altri è che se siamo
abituati a stupirci della nostra
quotidianità e siamo allenati a trovare
Appunto lo straordinario nell'ordinario
Allora siamo allenati Ogni giorno della
nostra vita a creare un nuovo sogno Così
da poterci sentire ogni giorno più vivi
Ora però da bravo mago sento un po' di
dubbi so che cosa stai pensando ancora
una volta sicuramente state pensando Sì
Francesco molto bello essere aiutati a
realizzare i propri sogni dalla
meraviglia ma nel concreto come si può
trovare la straordinarietà nel
quotidiano nell'ordinario Beh lasciate
ancora una volta che ve lo dimostri
Facciamo così prendete tutti i vostri
smartphone Mi raccomando fatelo tutti
Aprite tutti i vostri cellulari e per
favore Cercate di non concentrarvi sulle
centinaia di notifiche sicuramente
avrete ricevuto negli ultimi minuti
fatelo tutti e anche voi da casa che ci
state guardando attraverso uno schermo
anche voi prendete i vostri smartphone e
Aprite la calcolatrice d'accordo fatelo
tutti Aprite la calcolatrice dei vostri
cellulari lo faccio anch'io così che
possiate seguire il tutto e gentilmente
per esempio lei che in seconda fila Mi
può dire un numero qualsiasi a tre cifre
quello che vuole
113 Perfetto allora digitate tutti uno
uno tre e a questo punto premete per il
moltiplicatore e per esempio lei in
prima fila anche lei mi potrebbe dire
tre cifre quelle che preferisce
4 6 7 Fantastico Allora digitiamo tutti
quattro sei sette e ancora una volta
premiamo per il moltiplicatore e per
esempio magari con lei gentilmente mi
digiti i primi tre numeri che le vengono
fra le dita Sì sì digiti tre numeri a
caso e vi dica a tutti ad alta voce che
numeri mi ha digitato per cambiare un
po'
647 Allora anche noi premiamo tutti
insieme 6 4 7 e a questo punto premiamo
tutti uguale ovviamente il risultato che
tutti otterremo sarà 34 milioni
142.837 se qualcuno ha sbagliato eh
ragazzi Avete sbagliato a digitare Ok
Ora però abbiamo bisogno di qualcosa di
veramente ordinario Random caotico
quindi facciamo così gentilmente lei si
può avvicinare e solo io qua sul mio
cellulare premo meno e gentilmente mi
può mettere l'indice in su è importante
l'indice non il medio Mi raccomando e
guardi lascio il cellulare piegato così
lei prema un po' di tasti a caso quelli
che vuole Perfetto così che non si
diverta pure eh ok Non esageriamo ne ha
premuti un bel po' così che ora avremo
un numero veramente casuale Fatelo anche
voi anche voi premete meno e sottrateci
il numero che abbiamo appena creato
casualmente quindi dopo aver premuto
meno digitate
2/8 030
numero 1 5 quindi dal numero di prima ci
sottraiamo 28 milioni 0
30.815 Ora io blocco il mio cellulare
voi tutti premete uguale perché siete
d'accordo sarebbe veramente
straordinario Sei riuscito a indovinare
questo numero Ci provo eh non è facile
ovviamente noi non ci conosciamo con le
persone ha chiesto i numeri non ci siamo
mai visti prima d'ora assolutamente non
ci siamo messi d'accordo in alcun modo e
ovviamente poi abbiamo digitato anche un
numero a caso quindi io in alcun modo
non potevo sapere quale sarebbe stato il
numero che avreste creato voi quest'oggi
ora al mio Tre potete dire tutti ad alta
voce quale numero mi avete creato tutti
insieme 1 2 3
6 milioni
112.022 Beh Signore e signori è
veramente straordinario perché io qua ho
scritto 6 milioni 112.000 20 2
ma ama ancora una volta so che cosa
state pensando sicuramente qualcuno di
voi sarà pensando che in quanto studente
di farmacia magari Sono solo molto bravo
in matematica no vi assicuro che con i
conti sono una schiappa Ma siccome io
quest'oggi vi avevo promesso di
mostrarvi che si può trovare qualcosa di
straordinario nell'ordinario mesi fa
quando inviato queste slide allo staff
del Ted slide che non possono essere
modificati in alcun modo in queste slide
aveva nascosto una previsione per ognuno
di voi aveva nascosto che il numero
scelto di questa sera sarebbe stato 6
milioni 112.000 20 2
ma ma io quest'oggi vi avevo promesso di
dimostrarvi che si può davvero trovare
qualcosa di straordinario nell'ordinario
e che a volte i momenti più semplici e
quotidiani sono quelli più belli e
importanti sì questo era il mio
messaggio per ognuno di voi quest'oggi
oggi il giorno del The Dix il 6 novembre
Undicesimo mese dell'anno 2020 due
Allora sì forse è proprio vero che la
meraviglia È un diritto fondamentale al
quale ognuno di noi dovrebbe allenarsi
quotidianamente e che la magia è un'arte
Antica vecchia di migliaia di anni che
non è fatta solo di trucchi e segreti ma
che per me ha rappresentato un vero e
proprio approccio alla vita e mi ha
aiutato a raggiungere e realizzare la
maggior parte dei miei sogni e spero da
quest'oggi aiuterà anche a realizzare i
vostri perché forse aveva ragione Jordan
Show quando diceva che l'uomo non smette
di giocare perché invecchia ma invecchia
perché smette di giocare grazie